bonjour et bienvenue dans la deuxième
partie le 13 oct ok you're le monde sait
ce quiz et on se retrouve pour la
deuxième partie de dredd out où s'était
arrêtée juste là on avait tué un fantôme
aux ciseaux et tenter de nous couper la
queue de cheval et ça c'est pas pesé
comme prévu on a ramassé des ciseaux et
là du coup on peut couper les clés qui
sont autour du cou du porcine est situé
2 en bas de cet endroit
je propose bien évidemment qu'on y aille
or il est de retour
le cha allah que de rares il est bas en
panne est ce chien il a un gros gros
problème alors c'était en bas il faut
qu'on retrouve le porcine et comme je
l'appelle pour ceux qui ne se
souviennent pas c'est le fantôme le plus
shop de la planète puisqu'il ressemble à
ça oh [ __ ] mais à chaque fois
alors est-ce quoi enfin pouvoir s'enfuir
j'aimerais bien [ __ ] il est planqué
uss veut par là les poteaux est quand
même manière entre par les trop fortes
pour pousser la porte
attendez il doit il doit avoir sa petite
pièce en guise de dortoir c'est sûr et
certain
encore faut-il la trouvais porcine et
n'ont sûrement pas ici or si ghost ses
patins de sa boîte au il est là euh bon
bien sûr un [ __ ] mais moi je n'aurais
jamais osé faire ce à quoi il va me
pousser
vous avez trouvé la clé de l'école yes
aller au cours sans plus tarder je sens
qu'il va nous arriver une [ __ ]
d'énormes galère c'est sûr et certain on
ne peut pas s'enfuir de manière si
simple j'ai bien peur l'a déjà haut au
plus tard voilà vous avez dit quoi
depuis quand on est déjà tombé comme ça
dans les escaliers sur aucune raison
c'est que ça brett je peux passer à
travers ce collectif euh ok on les suit
on se jouera la fête mais c'est ça c'est
le fait que je précise juste que c'est
comme ça que j'arrive pas trop avoir
voulu dire que ce n'était pas les
meilleurs graphismes du monde au wat
mais c'est quoi ce fantôme on garde mais
sans déconner vous avez vu ça le photo
faisait 4 bet quoi une sorte d'animal
c'était le frère du port cid et on peut
le dire donc là c'est quand on décède on
se dirige vers la lumière
bon c'est une bonne chose attendez on a
on a un air à paris où là d'accord dans
le couloir de 120 m moi j'ai peur tiens
on va se faire agresser par un fantôme
de 4 mètres sur 8 les proportions de
meubles ikea quoi le truc oui la sortie
de l'école les repas des enfants toutes
ces portes quand même petit des
expressions qui se trouvait en route
en fait on est sûr randonnée simulateur
2014 c'est ça ah bah voilà
ah ouais ok date roll watts
ok donc l'époque pour drôlement la
gueule on sait désormais qui est le
meilleur cardio de la planète terre
c'est cette femme
on applaudit bien fort s'il vous plaît
oh oh attendez moi d'en faire comme dans
harry potter ou le temps tu allais
octobre ok espagne la porte cachée
bon apparemment on n'a pas le même
talent que les gens de raï potter alors
je pense qu'il faut garder téléphone
pour ouvrir ou véhicule
yes attend non pailhès ouais ok je te
fais un dessin d'un set pourquoi ya du
bruit
ahmed ouyahia la sortie juste lâché best
seller de s'enfuir
oh [ __ ]
tu peux tu pourrais tu nous fais une
grosse comme ça du flamenco
non non les spots heineken d'accord
alors est ce qu est une méthode pour
pour le flamenco je sais pas le flamenco
pour les nuls pouvez la firme comme j'en
ai marre de décéder j'en ai marre de
mourir et de briller je suis tout
florissante et je n'aime pas ça tu veux
pas rester ici pour toujours et il ya
des introductions quand même mais on a
plus de défenses et vous plaît mais moi
ça marche jamais mais [ __ ] je pense
qu'il faut courir concours concours et
je me faut que je fasse quoi pourquoi
elle rit pourquoi le ris est si drôle
que ça quand je courais pourquoi jude
saxophone marcolès fois avec ton
saxophone [ __ ] on va faire ton du truc
et retourner jusqu'à la porte et que si
tu sembles ils sont glyphes l'art il est
plus là [ __ ] je voulais qu'ils
m'aident
non allez moi à ta g t sur pauvre cruche
y avait une salle de biologistes ua pour
la biologie ces moments non je préfère
me courir après pour me défoncer
d'accord ok ok un nom mais [ __ ] il a
fait un temps de toiles d'araignées
dessus on peut plus aller si c'est bon
ok donc toi tu tu as mangé des cafards
tout va bien non c'est pas ce que c'est
mais ah non je fais suivre j'me fais
suivre par des [ __ ] d'insectes tas
mais il veut croire qu'abdallah tous
deux atteints je savais que je devais
acheter une prison sion tient c'est elle
veut qu'on se perde
on ne se plaindra jamais je connais cet
endroit plus que ma propre chambre
une petite photo les insectes ans de
partir pour la maison on peut pas ok et
juste derrière moi c'est bon sens en soi
on s'en sort personne ne peut me retenir
dans cet endroit de merde
bonjour toile d'araignée oui oh non pas
encore
ah d'accord donc après après les cafards
elle sort les lra le nom mais il fait
quoi sera à d'accord ok mais ces trois
corps quoi en fait les contrôles sont
totalement inversé j'ai obligé de
marcher comme ça par contre la lampe
torche nobita chat merde quel ou troll
quoi on va y arriver
non mais on va y arriver moi je voulais
dire à la biche oh [ __ ] c'est horrible
de l'avoir derrière comme ça tu sais
qu'elle amenderait en steak a voté par
terre allez fêtons clamé qu il est monté
ou simple et pouf casse toi casse toi
non c'est pas rond ah je sais je sais je
sais mais non mais l'espoir la douce
mode qu'il sait c'est impossible c'est
moi revivre jeunes rats dans le droit
commun on va partir sur un rush
monumental poc nickel là elle sort le
cafard peinture je suis de cafard hop
c'est l'heure du round je suis lorrain
relation de course alors je viens par le
poteau yes et maintenant la porte c'est
bon on l'a fait c'est fini non c'est une
blague encore je te prends en photo
assez drôle à y est on s'enfuit je
m'emballe c'était que je recherche la
porte instantanément sylvain trudel
c'est la fin
on s'est enfui de l'école c'est bon wat
qui sont ces gens d'où vient-il
ah d'accord ok d'accord très bien sort
de robert catteau déjà depuis dix années
de bep continue to be continue êtes
toubib coty en salle à et ben voilà on a
fini de raideurs au bas merci d'avoir
gardé ce très cool explique finalement
vu dans mes vidéos je fais pas mal de
coeur enfin je fais un gros con ans et à
chaque fois le jeu là il doit faire quoi
trois heures même pas même deux heures
je dirais voilà on a fini en 2 épisodes
encore merci à vous d'avoir suivi le les
semaines le plus petit du monde se voir
celui-ci recentré autour de nouvelles
vidéos tient tout le monde pis tu
reviens ici tout de suite tout de suite
dont tu reviens
de fait
hélas
je t'aime